hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today are going to be
going over game 5 from the 2013 World
Chess Championships the first 4 games
have all ended Benadryl good news for
the fans is every game has gotten
significantly better than the previous
game so if you'll remember from the
first couple games they pretty much just
moved a couple pieces immediately shook
hands and then took a day off the last
two games although both were drawls
actually went to the late-game
and they actually tried at least to try
to find some sort of win possibility
although it did in a draw so coming into
game five we have Magnus Carlsen playing
the white pieces and anons going to be
defending with the black pieces and you
haven't seen the game itself it is one
of the the most exciting games I've seen
it off so definitely please to go ahead
and go over it so Magnus Carlsen decided
to start with pawn to c4 a lot of people
just were expecting you know either that
Knight to f3 which we've seen maybe if
he found some you know better line and
one of the the games that he's already
played you know obviously these players
go back and look at their variations if
he didn't play this Knight to f3
probably he just didn't find anything
good with that and so one to try
something completely different which he
did because c4 we don't see very often
but we see this pawn to e6 again black
can really transpose into a lot of
different defenses neither side is
really you know locked in as far as what
they're going to do then we see this
pawn here to these four so kind of that
Queens gambit and then we see this upon
to d5 the Queen's game a decline line
and then after Knight to c3 we see pawn
to c6 also pretty common you could see
Knight here to f6 and then you know even
you know pawn to e3 Bishop e7 Knight to
f3 right here castle on the Kings side
you can see Bishop to e2 here getting
ready to cast over here this is what we
see most common but an on actually
decided to go into the semi slab line
and play pawn to c6 here recognizing
that later on he's going to have to get
his LightSquared Bishop outside of this
pawn chain you know a lot of times you
know if it stays right here this night
will come
year to d7 you'll have a night here on
d7 you also have a night here on f6
you'll kind of work from that really
depends on you know how the game goes
from here magnus carlsen even from here
played a rather interesting move I think
a lot of people were expecting either
Knight to f3 or pawn here to e3 which
are both very common you know ways to
attack the semi Slav defense instead
Magnus Carlsen went for a pretty
aggressive move in my opinion play pawn
to e4 again it's definitely sound but
definitely something you don't see very
often we now see black take on e4 and
then the Knights going to recapture and
now the bishops going to swing down here
now the Knights going to come back it's
a little awkward if Bishop plays here to
d2 you know because now the the Queen
comes back here takes on d4 and this is
just a situation that you know Magnus
Carlsen doesn't want to have to deal
with so instead he plays you know his
Knight to c3
now anon does have the option you could
just go ahead and take right here give
doubled pawns to Magnus Carlsen here on
the C file but again high level play
usually just don't see your opponent's
giving you know they're a person across
the table from them doubled bishops if
they don't have to so the Knights going
to come back here to c3 then and on
plays pawn to c5 just allowing this pawn
here to come to c5 if he wants to both
sides will go ahead and you know trade
off Queens and then this Bishop will
come here to c5 this will be a
completely fine game for black Magnus
Carlsen has other plants we push this
forward with a3 kind of forcing this
bishop back so we see the bishop come
back here and now we see some just
regular development obviously you want
to get all your pieces and bulbs to the
game nice to see three Knight to f3 are
both pretty common moves and so now we
see Knight to f6 and now we see Bishop
to e3 could have also seen you know one
of this other Bishop move getting ready
to castle I you know I think Magnus
Carlsen kind of looked at this and he
saw a lot of pressure building up on
this pawn you know on d4 here especially
if you know this starts to push forward
this Knight to c6 can get a little
interesting so you know playing this
this Bishop here to e3 also allows them
if you wanted to castle on the Queen
side although that would be pretty
tricky it you know you
and he's continuing his develop from
here so the Knights now going to come to
c6 again as we talked about before
typically in the semi Slav this nights
going to come here to d7 but if the
pawns kind of move around which we have
you know this pawn on c6 and d5 are no
longer there then this is a much more
natural move for the night here on c6 -
again attacks on it kind of that center
of the board here on before so now we
see the Queen come to d3 for two reasons
one you know really don't want to have
to have this bishop take here on on c3
and then these doubled pawns so this
Queen here on d3 not only protects this
night here on c3 but it's still you know
holding down this pawn here on d4 also
protects this pawn here on C for another
movie you know Magnus Charlton could
have also just played rook over here to
c1 you know both are going to be
completely fine the Queen here on d3
also allows him if he wants to castle on
the Queen side but you know he could
always play this this rook over here to
c1 you know play this bishop here to e2
castle on the King side and have a
really good game in the game the Queen
comes to d3 and then after the the pawn
takes and the pawn recaptures this nice
going to come here to g4 pretty
aggressive move from an on you know
threatening to take this fish appear on
a e3 black would now have the double
bishop pair Magnus Carlsen now plays an
interesting movie plays King casts on
the Queen side now if you look at again
the king isn't super safe he does have a
lot of pieces in front of them but you
know again there's not a lot of pawn
structure in front of this so definitely
an interesting move but also again very
aggressive for Magnus Carlsen to say you
know what this is going to be completely
fine I don't mind you know having my
King exposed a little bit because I'm
going to be attacking for the rest of
the game so non goes and plays this a
knight here takes on e3 again this is
one of those where you know he wants to
have that double Bishop pair and now the
pawns going to take on e3 and it's
always important to realize how you
should take you would actually somewhat
be of a mistake if you know the the
Queen took here on e3 you can now see
the bishop come back to b6 again putting
pressure on this square right here we
can now see this knight come up here too
b5 again you know protecting this right
here and then but then after you know
the castle on the Kings side we could
have this pawn push forward right here
again this night can't really move too
much because it's being pinned down you
could also see you know this pawn here
just coming to a6 that would also you
know take away one of these defenders
right here on d4 so a lot of different
ways then black can attack this but
instead you know it's much easier since
White's castle down the Queen side he's
not too worried about moving this this
pawn here on f2 so it decides to go
ahead and just take with this pawn and
now he does have you know this e pawn
center of the board which is always good
but he does have to be careful Magnus
Carlsen has kind of three pawn
structures right now so going in towards
the endgame he doesn't have the best
pawn structure but he has a much more
active position in this game right now
so then we see the bishop come back here
to c7 and magnus carlsen decides a good
time to go ahead and start exchanging so
after we exceed the exchanges right here
now black also has three pawn structure
so you know pawn over here upon over
here pawns over here so you know again
both sides equal in material white
definitely has a little bit more of an
active position he has you know there's
one completely open file and he's
controlling it with his his Dirac right
here so that's definitely good he has a
knight and a bishop which can do
extremely well together
you know a nan does have this double
bishop here but they're not doing too
much right now again this lights for a
bishop for for black hasn't moved which
it really moves in the semi Slav defense
so something to keep in mind this Bishop
is now going to come to e2 and we now
see the King come to e7 again once the
Queen's are off the board you're not too
worried about your King safety doesn't
have to castle and so you know as we
approach the the endgame you actually
want to have your King involved in the
game so an on just decides to play e7
because you know he can swing this rook
but he wants to have his King actually
centralized more so than in this corner
here on g8 so now the bishop is going to
come to f3 again starting to attack get
it more involved into the game we now
see black just defend with his bishop
here on d7 and then we see the knight
come over here too
for in more centralized Square getting
all of us pieces involved into the game
and now we see the bishop come over here
to b6 doesn't really do much because now
just the pawn can push forward to c5
since it's being protected add a little
bit more pressure but anon decides to go
ahead and just exchange pieces off
there's no great square for this night
to go to you know it is the defender of
the square and so magnus carlsen just
decides to go ahead and trade these off
push forward which is just going to be a
little exchange and so after we exchange
right here Magnus Carlsen swoops over
and plays rook over here to f1 and so if
we kind of look at it now we've come
down pieces so both sides still have the
same amount of material white still has
a much more active position there's to
open files on the board magnus carlsen
as you can imagine completely owns both
of them with this rooks here on D 1 and
F 1 so if we kind of look at how this is
going to go what's what's white trying
to do why it's really looking to attack
all the pawns on the light squares
really control you know these long files
also wants to make sure that black has
you know kind of a cramped position
right now blacks not very active so
black wants to be active and so that's
going to be an ons game plan he wants to
go ahead and get his rooks involved into
the game he wants this light score a bit
should be doing more than it is because
right now it's just kind of hanging back
here so those are what both sides are
kind of looking to do in this position
the NAM plays rook here to b5 getting
ready to come over here to e5
threatening both this bishop and this
pawn here on the e-file so Magnus
responds with his rook over here to f4
you know protecting this the palm pushes
forward to g5 and so the rooks going to
have to move comes back here you know
now even if the rook swings over that's
going to be fine he can move this bishop
and his pawns still going to be
protected so in this particular case
again just brings it back here and the
pawns now going to come to h5 no reason
to bring the rook over here it's not
really having any threat and so you know
h5 and then we see the rook swing over
here to to f1 kind of have this
battering ram over here starting to
attack we now see the Bishop to e8 again
the bishops not doing
too much it's still pretty passive in
the game it really has it really gotten
too involved into the game now we see
the bishop come back here to see - and
then the rook coming over here again
very aggressive square for this rook
here on c5 it's very centralized has a
lot of different squares that's
protecting in this again this Bishop is
being pinned down so white wants to
definitely make sure he gets out of this
pit now we're going to see the rook come
up here to f6 and then blacks just going
to push forward again anytime you have
pawns it's important to push him just to
put more pressure on your opponent so
that's what magazine Carlson does he
decides to try to control the center of
the board with this pawn right here you
know towards the late game you know with
rooks on the board it's a little bit
different but you know if we can
exchange all these rooks off the board
you always want to have your pawns on
the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop so in this case you would want
all your pawns eventually on dark
squares now again with rooks on the
board it doesn't mean as much just
because the rooks can pretty much take
anything so from here we're going to see
pawn push forward to a5 again trying to
threaten you know both sides of the
board pushing not only on the Kings side
but the Queen side as well now we see
the King come to d2 wants to make sure
that he's not being pinned down right
here and now again not just continues to
pressure plays rook over here to b5
controlling the semi open file attacking
this pawn right here pushes forward
again no real threats now the bishop -
to h5 this is kind of the first time
this LightSquared bishop for black has
really gotten to the game so that was he
king here - c3 and now again check and
not the king comes back here to be -
nicely tucked back here it's no in real
danger right now
now the rook swings over to d8 and then
after we have you know this you know
this rook is threatening to come down
here to d2 which is going to be really
really tough for white to deal with so
Magnus Carlsen plays f2 and now this
works going to swing down to d4 and as
you can see just in a matter of about 6
or 7 moves black is done exactly what he
needed to do he needed to get more
aggressive he needed to get his pieces
involved into the action
you know Magnus Carlsen moved away from
this D file and so black immediately
took control of it he needed to get his
light-square bishop involved into the
game
age five is not the most you know
efficient that it can be but it's
definitely a lot better than it was so
this is kind of even for both sides uh
nobody has a clear advantage right now
black has definitely done a better job
of you know getting to this point where
white had definitely a small advantage
but that's kind of evaporated by now
now the rooks are going to swing over to
h6
and we see the bishop come down here to
d1 and then the bishop comes back again
doesn't want to have to worry about any
of these crazy exchanges and then the
works going to swing over here to b5 and
things start to get a little crazy we
see the king up here after pawn to f5
black is actually threatening mate now
we see the rook can now come to b2 or b3
excuse me and threaten mate which again
is important that this pawns here now
there's a nice little outpost for this
rook here on v4 and because white has
the lights where bishop he really can't
do a whole heck of a lot to disrupt this
so white has to you know respond to this
made him one so he brings his rook over
here to be to kind of protecting this
but you know anon is really forcing the
action right here and kind of forcing
white to kind of stay back and defend so
the pawn comes to e5 so this is again
kind of double having this outpost right
here but this rook on h6 is still kind
of a pain for black you can really not
get his King involved into the action
which you'd really like because you know
why it just completely dominates this
sixth rank right here so why it's going
to start to put some pressure on the
pawns over here since this pawn on e4 is
kind of blocking any of the action of
the rooks getting involved and so we see
pawn here to a4 and then we see just the
exchange so both sides decide to go
ahead and take some ponds and a few
pieces come off the board and now white
comes over here and takes on e5 and then
after the King takes we see the rook
swing back over here to h4 and threaten
so if we kind of look at it all of a
sudden a few moves gone by and what
looked like a pretty strong attack
Magnus Carlsen
was able to find a nice little advantage
as we come to it now the rook is going
to swing over here to d1 and then you
know whites going to push forward from
here after the King moves in the bishop
comes back here then we see rook to c1
and this was really where the game fell
apart for non as far as where he should
have gone
something like rook to a1 makes a lot of
sense again threatening this pawn on a3
no real way to hold on to it's a you
know long term and so this is going to
be fine for black but in the game again
he played this rook here to c1 and
because of that hands up losing material
so you know the King comes here to be
too threatening the roofs got to move so
the rook comes over here and now this
bishop can swing into the action to g8
this King is forced to move a little in
between move before he takes this bishop
so you know the rook swings up here to
h6 and then after the King moves and the
bishop takes then the king is going to
take this pawn here on b3 so again that
small little move from an on just to say
hey I'm going to bring my rook over here
to see one instead of adding more
pressure over here male say on a1 again
he's now down to material and from here
you know again there's just not much an
on can do he's just down too much
material you know it does take this this
G pawn but then this H pawn right here
and Magnus Carlsen has ponds on the a
file and the H file that he can just
push up the board so it's going to be
extremely extremely difficult especially
Magnus Carlsen being one of the best in
game players in the world just very very
sharp when it comes to tactical lines
there was just no hope from here from
anon so he did decide to go ahead and
play things out a little bit more you
know Magnus Carlsen wasn't even worried
about this pawn on the e rank he just
decided to go ahead and start pushing
forward so the pawn is going to push
forward the rook swings over but that's
okay because 87 is being protected by
this rook over here and then after the
King to h4 or c5 then h4 by this pawn
pushing forward again can't really
protect both of them this
working just swing over here to g7 if
you wanted to start pushing forward over
even further if you wanted again you
can't stop both of these and so this
particular case anon decided to go ahead
and resign so an exciting game again
game five we finally have our first win
I know some people out there we're
hoping and praying that we didn't have
all drawls but if you remember even in
the last game I as I was watching it on
play it just seemed like he couldn't
find the calculations that he usually
does I don't know if he's he's nervous
or he's tired or if he's intimidated by
Magnus Carlsen but Magnus Carlsen always
found these small little advantages he
couldn't quite come up with a win the
last two games but with the white and
black pieces Magnus Carlsen was
dominating and so I just felt like he
was all it took was kind of a longer
game like this one this this game took
almost six hours so you know these
longer games where Magnus Carlsen can
kind of grind down his opponent actually
think Magnus Carlsen will will kind of
snowball this I don't know if he'll win
you know the next one with black pieces
I think you'll play somewhat
conservative try to take a draw and go
into the next game you know being up you
don't have to try anything too crazy but
I actually think that he'll actually get
a win and one of the next few games know
what kind of snowball out of control and
none will have to play aggressive and
try to go for a win and Magnus Carlsen
will take that find a mistake and
actually end up winning a few more games
so I'm excited definitely a great game
hopefully you guys are enjoying this
series and I'll see you all in the next
game thanks for watching